les épisodes de panique et une psychose
collective ont toujours accompagné
l'aventuré humaine récemment
l'apparition sur plusieurs plate forme
d'un personnage à l'alluré lugubre à
semer un vent de panique chez des
parents inquiets pour leurs enfants
juliet des pros créateur du balado pas
de panique s'est intéressé à ce qui est
appelé le mont au cha rock c'est en 2018
véritablement que la panique s'installe
c'est un service si court départ de
cette histoire c'est une légende urbaine
que des actes d adolescence raconté prix
du sucre comment ça marche des
adolescents fois qu'une légende urbaine
dont on va essayer d'en profiter sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on
disait que momo civis et c'était un
message que tu recevais d'un personnage
appelé momo qui t'invite à te faire du
mal ça c'est ce que la légende urbaine
raconté milieu d année 2010
c'était très peu reconnue comme
phénomène en 2018
le phénomène ressort et là c'est rendu
beaucoup plus que quelqu'un qui envoient
des messages textes ça apparaîtrait dans
des vidéos youtube
c'est un retraité jeunes enfants de
faire du mal là c'est plus juste les
adolescents un jeu d'horreur qui joue
entre adolescents et les parents
commencent un peu à faire mais qu'est ce
que nos enfants font sur les réseaux
sociaux s'en inquiète les parents les
parents commencent à écrire des
publications sur facebook j'ai entendu
parler du mode challenge entendu parler
du monde challenge mon enfant en vue ce
sens est faite par là l'école et c'est
comme ça que la panique ce cri il ya
cette figure ce personnage requis et
karne le mode challenge
jusqu'où ça va ça quand on dit que ça
incite les jeunes à se faire du mal qu
est ce qui est vrai qu est ce qu il faut
pas ce que l'on a entendu des choses il
ya aucune des vidéos qu'on a vu circuler
qui n'ont pas été faites à la blague ou
par des adolescents qui voulait juste
participe au final mieux personnes selon
moi qui voulais vraiment incité des gens
faire du mal c'est un phénomène viral
qui était repris par sur leur ai dit sur
facebook sur you tôt par des youtuber
qui ont décidé de faire des blagues qui
envoyait sa leurs amis mais là ça sera
marc sur les réseaux sociaux dont il ya
des parents qui voient ça qu'ils sont
convaincus que leurs enfants ont vu ça
dans un vidéo youtube sur la chaîne pour
enfants c'est
les défis morbide sur internet revient
en argentine
ce geste aurait poussé une jeune fille
de 12 ans à s'enlever la vie et se
trouvent écho ça dans les bulletins
nouvelle dans les journaux dans les
bulletins radio
évidemment les parents sont terrorisés
les écoles sont sur un pied d'alerté
c'est une part que les enfants n'ont pas
à la base mon monde
ils n'ont pas peur en écoutant youtube
d'une figure va apparaître pour leur
dire faites au a du mal fait fait du mal
à tes amis c'est les parents qui ont par
dessus parce qu'ils savent pas ce qu'ils
font sur leur téléphone fait que les
parents en jasant jalousement on va
aller voir la directrice l'école at on
entendu ça et tu connais la game du
téléphone arabe
c'est comme ça que la panique mot
commence et se rend dans les médias mais
momo là dedans il reste anecdotique
c'est une figure parfaite pour
représenter toutes les angoisses des
parents sur ce que leurs enfants font
sur leur téléphone ou leur tablette